[Música]
economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna me acompaña en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches vamos a
comenzar en Estados Unidos en donde ya
se ha normalizado en cierta forma el
tráfico aéreo en ese país después del
fallo de sistemas que provocó miles de
retrasos y algunas cancelaciones en los
vuelos específicamente alrededor de
10.000 vuelos fueron afectados con
retrasos o cancelaciones los
legisladores estadounidenses estudiarán
la causa de esta interrupción del
sistema informático de la Administración
Federal de Aviación las autoridades
aéreas estadounidenses suspendieron
durante horas las salidas de vuelos en
todo el país tras una falla que afectó
este sistema clave que usan los pilotos
antes del despegue según la Casa Blanca
no se trata de un ciberataque esta nueva
interrupción se produce tras el colapso
a gran escala en Estados Unidos durante
las vacaciones de Navidad cuando una
tormenta provocó el caos con miles de
vuelos retrasados O cancelados solamente
para darnos una idea este miércoles
había programado un total de 21 464
vuelos en todos los aeropuertos de
Estados Unidos con una capacidad de
carga de casi 2,9 millones de pasajeros
según los datos de sirio pasemos ahora a
hablar de Western Union que reanudó la
envío de remesas entre Estados Unidos y
Cuba pero pero con restricciones bueno
Esto luego de dos años desde que el
entonces presidente Donald Trump de
Estados Unidos endureciera las
restricciones impuestas de por Estados
Unidos hacia Cuba hasta tras esta
relajación de las medidas de parte del
gobierno de la administración de Joe
biden se implementó una fase de prueba
en Miami ahora las transferencias se
pueden enviar a tres bancos operados por
el gobierno en Cuba el Banco Popular de
ahorro el banco Metropolitano sai
también el banco de crédito y comercio
Western Union comunicó que los pagos no
se pueden enviar por internet y que el
dinero sólo se puede transferir en
dólares los envíos están limitados a
2000 dólares al día y el dinero debe ser
reti con una tarjeta de identificación
cubana las remesas podrían dar cierto
alivio a las familias cubanas en un
momento de crisis económica sin
precedentes y que es uno de los factores
que también está alimentando la
migración pasemos ahora a hablar del
peso mexicano que superó la Barrera de
las 19 unidades por dólar por primera
vez en tres años Qué es lo que está
pasando porque se aprecia la moneda
mexicana bueno la moneda cotiza en torno
a los 18,95 pesos por dólar y es un
mejor nivel de de finales de 2020 este
avance del peso se debe a que los
operadores esperan que las cifras de la
inflación de diciembre de Estados Unidos
un dato que se va a conocer este jueves
muestren una desaceleración lo que
llevaría la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos a detener su ciclo alcista en los
tipos de intereses o sea en el precio
del dinero también ayudaron las subidas
de los tipos de interés en México así
como el histórico nivel de remesas que
recibió ese país alrededor de entre
enero y noviembre del 2022 México
recibió 53 mil millones de dólares y
esto también ayudó para que el peso
mexicano sea ahora mismo el favorito
entre los operadores o traders que
quieren apostar A favor o en contra de
países emergentes en todo el mundo la
moneda mexicana se apreció un
4,87% anual en comparación con dos mil
veintiuno siendo la mejor recuperación
de la divisa desde el año 2012 Por eso
ahora inclusive le dicen el súper peso
súper peso mexicano pasemos ahora a
hablar de Venezuela en donde ha habido
varias protestas desde diferentes
sectores de la economía de ese país
porque están pidiendo mejoras salariales
que tan posibles es esto bueno
funcionarios públicos del sistema de
salud y también educadores y algunos
jubilados Se tomaron las calles de
Caracas y la inflación y la dolarización
de Venezuela están ampliando la brecha
salarial entre los trabajadores del
sector público y privado los empleados
públicos ganan el equivalente a entre 30
y 100 dólares al mes según las
revisiones salariales del gobierno pese
a cierta recuperación económica en
Venezuela los datos son negativos la
inflación anual en octubre del 2022
alcanzó el 155% la más alta en la región
y más de la mitad de los venezolanos
viven en pobreza el último aumento del
salario mínimo fue en marzo del 2022
cuando el gobierno de Venezuela fijó el
aumento en 130 bolívares soberanos Que
al momento eran unos 30 dólares
mensuales Y actualmente son apenas 7 y
para el cierre hablamos de Israel porque
el nuevo gobierno de este país habló
ahora de reducción o eliminación de
algunos impuestos de cuáles bueno
específicamente en bienes inmuebles y
también el costo del agua y la energía
esto es parte de un paquete de medidas
del Primer Ministro benjamina tanyahu
para contener la inflación entre las
medidas que anunció figuran la
subvención del precio de la gasolina
congelar las subidas del impuesto de
bienes inmuebles y rebajar las subidas
previstas del costo de la electricidad y
el agua Pero el gobierno no aclaró De
dónde sal unos fondos suplementarios la
inflación anual de Israel alcanzó el
5,3% en noviembre pasado su nivel más
alto desde octubre del 2008 Jorge muchas
gracias por esta ampliación de los temas
destacados de la economía de la jornada
de hoy a continuación en directo América
el debate
[Música]